okay oh no I want that no okay I think
what ah oh the Sun is shifting god
dammit
it's Thursday you're on that's grace
it's what is this take off
tipsy Thursday no someone else had that
just a tip Thursday I don't know anyway
today I'm going to teach you how to do
something yay Father's Day is coming up
and I don't know if that's an
international holiday anyway Father's
Day is coming up but today just
celebrate your dad so I thought I would
help you come up with fun creative
quirky gift ideas for him
what did dads love coffee what does
coffee come in mugs why not make your
dad a personalized coffee mug I've come
up with some designs here of how you can
personalize it to make it a really fun
mug your dad will love or appreciate I
don't have actual coffee mugs I just
drew up my designs here my daughter is
underdeveloped emotionally because I was
too busy drinking coffee my favorite
song is buy buy buy that's for you dad
happy Father's Day
my favorite movie is Gone with the Wind
happy Father's Day my favorite TV show
is family I psyche it's the biggest
loser happy Father's Day
child support more like child abort am i
right happy Father's Day I have a
drinking problem
happy Father's Day remind me to buy my
daughter's love have a Father's Day this
coffee isn't the only thing that
disappeared happy Father's Day I like my
coffee like I like my mistresses
black-eye Father's Day I like my coffee
like I like my mistresses with create
actually this joke is too gross I'm
bailing on it just like I did with my
kids happy Father's Day there you go
there are some creative cute quirky mug
ideas that you can give your dad for
Father's Day I
I feel like I could do this my dad's
awesome and I love him very much and
none of this is based on any reality of
me not loving my father do guys say that
for the few out there that we're gonna
leave some stuff on tumblr being like
Grace has daddy issues I got way more
issues than just daddy issues Grace's
guide book calm